netflix has seen months of growth as
more people seek home entertainment
during the pandemic
in its second quarter the company says
it added more than 10 million
subscribers globally and made more than
6 billion
in revenue now the company's founder and
co-ceo
reed hastings has a new book no rules
rules
netflix and the culture of reinvention
it's about what he says
is an unorthodox company culture leading
to greater success
reid hastings good morning thanks for
being with us
thank you very much your book is based
on a 127
slide powerpoint that you put together
back in 2009
to to sort of lay out your company's
culture
but one of the things that you you point
out is that the aim of the culture
is to give your employees freedom like
avoiding rules
which would seem to be a contradiction
when you have a 127
point slide presentation how do you
explain that
takes a lot of slides to talk about
freedom and
you know we've had such success at
trying to create uh
shows and films that people are gonna
love
and a lot of that is because we give our
employees freedom what do you mean when
you say freedom
i mean the people get to make decisions
throughout the company
people get to decide let's commission
this show i don't have to get
five levels of approval or let's do this
feature
i don't need to get five levels of
approval so we encourage
people throughout the company to make
decisions you also talk about
transparency and communication
absolutely i mean if people are going to
make decisions then you want to give
them a lot of information we call it
context
and so what the book really does is go
through
from a organizational view how do you
set things up so you can have a lot of
freedom
without having chaos yeah how do you do
that
well then you got to buy the book
anthony no rules rules
oh come on really it's our it's our
internal
you know it's just really aimed at
organizations um
who are trying to have employees be
excited about what's going on
in their company and in our case that's
helped us move from
dvds that we were big in a decade ago
right to beings
popular and successful in film and
television you you write that that
netflix's success is based
in on having a star in every position
by using what you call the keeper test
explain what that is
sure we're like a professional sports
team
and if you're going to win a
championship in professional sports
you have to have amazing player in every
position
and so we push our managers to think
about do they have the right people
and by that we say the keeper test would
they work to keep the person
if that person were going to another
company
you does that breed the content of i
mean does that breed a culture of fear
though some people suggest it might
you know there are pockets of that but
not generally think of great athletes
they can get injured at any time
but they don't focus on the fear they
focus on the joy the fun the excellence
the competition the winning
and that's like our employees too you
released 2 700
hours of original content last year
almost double
what you did the year before but
production has been shut down
it's now restarted starting gradually
how are you going to how are you going
to keep this flow of content in in the
current climate
well the stuff we're working on now
we're producing now will be on next year
and we're able to produce a little bit
in the u.s but
canada we're able to produce in europe
asia so we've got a great line up for
next year
what about safety precautions on the
production and the production sets
yeah they're extensive as you would
imagine you know testing when you enter
so lots of protocols to keep people safe
but it is a struggle i mean this cove
it's a tough situation
but we're doing enough testing to make
people uh
feel safe and to make sure that we can
you know produce
great content where you know you don't
notice that there's any covet
as we reported on this broadcast uh you
and your wife patty announced
an extraordinary 120 million dollar
contribution to support scholarships
at historically black colleges uh and
university
yet your website lists uh only two
people of color
uh between your company's upper ranks do
you have a plan to diversify netflix
so our website for executives lists
about
20 people and the senior executives and
five of them are leaders of color
um so we're about 25 leaders of color
and about 50 percent women 50
men it's on the website under directors
and officers
so you so you are you satisfied with the
diversification you have then
we're making great progress compared to
where we were three years ago
but really diversity is about having
such curiosity about you know the many
different stories that people bring
and the more diversity we have the more
interesting the stories we tell are
all right reid hastings thank you very
much the book is no
rules rules it is on sale today